I wanted before we wrap this up I know
that you had you want to talk about
something near and dear to your heart
which is you have a new you have a dog
for the first time in a long time Oh in
in over 50 years and she only arrived a
few hours ago at our house I've longed
for this moment to come and she's a
female which is you know women's day
it's very very important tonight we're
we're going to be fostering her and she
arrived at our door and we have a little
video give a video if this is your first
dog in 50 years old oh yeah I had
already I had a border collie Rover and
Rover had to be put down when I was like
12 13 and we replaced him right so this
is the replace and you just met this dog
this is the moment that we're going to
see the moment right now let's take a
look at this this is fantastic
[Music]
her name is ginger
she comes from a pit bull fighting ring
she was a breeding dog for a fighting
ring they're all over the country every
state has these things and they're very
cruel the dogs get hurt and harmed but
now she's with us but we are only
fostering her and we are looking for a
permanent home for right right this is
what we're going to be doing as a sort
of middle man between the kennel the
kennels the homes and a permanent home
well this is a great message if anyone
out there is watching and you see ginger
and you could live in your home let us
know through the show or on our website
where we are going to be we've already
tweeted about her there will be more
social media and we will have all the
contact details there for anyone who is
looking for a beautiful playful handsome
happy dog
you